I literally saw somebody laying down
with the I guess the rubber band and
they the needle in them still and I'm
like wait what the hell like this would
never happen years ago because that type
of stuff you would do inside because you
don't want to people to see you or I
guess you would get in trouble is not
like the right thing to do but now it's
very open it's okay to do it like I can
just lay here and just shoot myself up
and get high and then wake back up and
go about my
business here in New York the migrant
cres 100,000 migrants people seeking
Asylum are cred together controversial
migrant shelter in Brooklyn New
yor over death in New York City after a
string of Ries and assault attackers
under arrest crime in the city have
arrived in New York
my name is Franchesca um I have five
kids I've lived here all my life we've
always had like U on once you get out
125 Street you know people will be there
either drugged up or trying to get some
drugs they'll be hung over um like doing
like that Michael Jack
lean over before it was really you know
you see a little bit of it there so you
can like avoid it and go across the
street you'll be okay but then we came
to school in September and we found out
the injection site was over there and
we're like wait what across the street
from a school like this doesn't make any
sense whatsoever cuz our babies are in
there like this this doesn't Co it
shouldn't coexist they shouldn't be
together
it got really bad to the point where we
had our February 1 panelist of meeting
and we expressed our concerns and then
they started having like I don't know
around maybe March April they started
having people walk around the buildings
but it's still over the summer we told
them it's going to get really bad and it
did you would see at least about 20 to
30 people just on that block and some of
these people people are stumbling over
themselves or they're pooping they
leaving poop on the corner on um Park
it's just really nasty or you see like
needles at the beginning you see needles
all over the place and we're just like
what is going on I don't want to speak
on behalf of all parents but there are
some parents where we feel like first
off this should never happen like there
should never have been a injection site
across the street from any
school there was a time where they used
to go on nature walk they sing like
leaves are falling you know like they
sing all that stuff you can do that
outside and bring the classroom outside
with them but our kids don't do that
anymore because of the neighborhood and
the way it's changed and to be very
honest I would be a parent which I've
had other parents say like they don't
want their kids going on walks no more
all it takes is one second for something
to go wrong so and I know the staff
there I know they would protect my kids
like if they were their own so I don't
have a problem with the staff doing the
walks it's more about the neighborhood
that it is now which I'm concerned with
and I don't
trust I'm
sry I feel like on point needs to get
better at taking care of their people
like their people that come in there to
get injected because like I get it you
want to help them you want to give them
clean needles and you provide a safe
haven for them but like you're not
really helping them out because like
eventually you're not going to be there
and they're going to overdose and
they're going to be dead in the street
those type of facilities you get all
types of people in the neighborhood and
we all know like when you walk up that
block you see them out there I don't
know what they're selling I don't know
what's going on there but like you know
that they're there to get the
individuals that's in there that's
trying to either recover or clean up or
take their Med take their
drugs they just need the help and not
being taken advantage of at their
weakest moment cuz it can change
depending on that moment so when they go
into one point they go there they do
what they need to do and then they come
out and there's even more access to any
other type of drug if they wanted the
right way do it do it in a way where
you're going to help these people not
them and then have them in an
alley or in the apartment or in a
building shooting up for one last time
and then they pass away and die that's
why the rate is going so
high I'm not surprised surpris I'm not
surprised at all that's because of the
on point
sites I don't think it's serving a
purpose at all like I I think they're
crippling people they're allowing people
to just get high and encouraging it and
it's not really helping them within the
inner the inner self like how can you
help somebody feel better when you're
tearing them on to get
high you should care because it's it's
our kids like our kids are pure they
have like imagination they have
creativity they should not be
experiencing seeing that stuff and you
have to talk to them about it I just
think we need help in this neighborhood
because we're revamping everything like
if you look around these buildings are
beautiful and big and everything's
coming up but we have that right there
on Park Avenue a a a facility for
getting high like we're trying to clean
up every neighborhood not dump a onsite
injection spot across street from a
early a Early Head Start program you
know like we need help they need help we
need to find a grounds for both sides
I'm not saying shut on point and be like
forget all those people that need the
help and need the clean needles but I'm
also saying like look at our kids like
our kids shouldn't be seeing this stuff
they're happy little kids they shouldn't
be scared or oh what's going on across
the street like why is all those you
know like just we need
help